mas se vocês vocês já eram
obrigatoriamente têm de deixar aqui o
bike tempo jô deixou o lado pessoal do
que quem fala andar que exige muito
menino está na visão dele o gaúcho nós
vamos fazê lo como estarão comigo 4 e
outro com essa cara de sono porque é
precisamente meia-noite agora eu vou
fazer sentido madrugada e não pode ser
nada eu vou falar mais inglês já soa
muito obrigado pelo que fizeram no
último vídeo como a citar um único
trecho já não estava vídeo é mesmo tempo
e mesmo assim o vídeo atingiu mais de um
milhão de visualizações de mais 100 mil
apps 25 mil só que foi o meu muito
obrigado pelo apoio e por isso o homem
porque de madrugada desculpa e meus
amigos eu não posso também todos os
vídeos né
enfim só a prova de hoje nós vamos usar
a máscara de quem os amigos querem lá
hoje e vamos tentar ser mais tarde o
corpo só vou tentar usar a máscara da
freira vamos tentar ajustar o pedido da
meia noite até às três da manhã oca por
que não também fica muito tarde por não
conseguir editar o vídeo e não consigo
estar windows pra vocês vai ser assim no
canal às minhas regras é assim e deixe
muito mais que meus filhos eram só se
nós conseguirmos bater o recorde do
vídeo anterior
eu faço ainda mais rápido como ele tal
como está como está o amigo 5 500
antes de começarmos realmente os sustos
quero passar uma novidade aqui eu estou
no cabelo lindo queremos vamos anunciar
que iria 20 de julho eu gostar não foram
ao lugar para estar com todos vocês não
me dizem é mas não é somente em ok vocês
também podem participar num concurso
onde vão poder ganhar prêmios esse
concurso foi organizado pelo fórum
algarve é um concurso foram por onde
vocês vão ter que fazer um vídeo
criativo e um vídeo que tiveram mais
likes no facebook a página do fórum
algarve vai deixar comigo 20 minutos
mais ou menos em cima do palco
exclusivamente comigo vai ser uma zona
possa começar mais à vontade com os
vencedores que você 2 e os dois
vencedores para além de poderem estar
comigo em palco vocês vão poder ganhar
também do oeste go pro chico se os dois
só participem as regras vão estar todas
no facebook do fórum algarve no
instagram também eu vou deixar que os
links todos resume andamento foram ao
lugar dia 20 de julho eu vou lá estar
participando até lá pessoal por concurso
está quase a acabar participar e eu vou
poder dar duas com o projeto e vou poder
estar comigo vamos dar aquele abraço
vamos tentar aqui no brasil mais de
perto
e agora pessoal vamos lá então para o
curso está um amigo fura ó
a mãe que está doente nem refletir
cérebro da deputada a contenda promotor
mesmo tratamento que ele está muito
feliz com meus filhos eu não sei que
disse também que não espera chão como
assustar um amigo 4 miguel como assustar
um amigo 4 mas amanhã ele é nosso amigo
[Música]
i fernando 0 voltando para uma escola
pio e já está entregue ao bié e vai mais
pra fora
o próxima vez de aprender brincar é se
ele vai voltar ver
[Música]
ó
já os causos não pega nem por onde estou
mas a fumaça está num bom nome
já tinha visto a mulher
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a gente tem que falar para o meu pai que
foi realmente não quero ficar aqui até
então o que vai acontecer só 13 e veja
e tu não estás a fazer essa [ __ ] para
com essa criança não quer entrar no
outro são paulo ii e que do copo para
nós aqui para dar andamento a ser uma
mulher seja só achei muito ricos foi
muito assistindo agora na televisão vai
mais longos a marca para observá la
dormir também já está ambientado